which we are live at Google headquarters
at the Google i/o Developers Conference
where Xiaomi and Hugo Barra just
unveiled a new set-top box for the US
market called the me box so you've
already got your line of me TVs how does
the meed box fit into your bigger vision
so me box was just right here so that
everybody sees it is a TV streaming
device what some people call an OTT or
set-top box we've been making TV devices
for a while now in China we make TVs big
TV sets up to 70 inches now but we also
make these boxes these are actually
incredibly popular because it's a way to
get content you know pretty easily over
the Internet
the world has been moving away from
linear TV right so these actually become
more important than like a cable set-top
box so why should I in the u.s. buy this
over Google's or Amazon set-top box or
an Apple TV so we're bringing them who
are packing quite a bit in here both
hardware and software really fast
processor we're using a chipset that's
commonly used on mobile phones right so
it's really fast for games for example
and we're introducing some video
capabilities that are pretty unique also
60 frames per second 4k video this new
thing called aged HDR which is a new
kind of video format that the likes of
Netflix and Vudu are introducing new
content for so it's a it's a great part
any runs Android TV right which is one
of the most important things because
with Android TV comes essentially all of
googles innovation their services Google
Play YouTube and so on so it's a pretty
amazing package so when will it be
available on how much will it cost we
were seeing everything except that in
that we're previewing it here at i/o it
was a great opportunity we're launching
it in collaboration with Google and
we'll be launching it in a few months
it'll certainly happen within this year
and the price will be pretty amazing as
you'd expect from us so you also
announced that you're gonna be making a
daydream ready Phone daydream is
Google's new mobile platform for virtual
reality how quickly do you think these
phones will take off what will they be
able to do
so first of all I think it's a massive
initiative for our industry because what
Google is doing here is they're saying
let's focus on the thing that matters
which is the mobile platform right
that's what we all carry in our pockets
but let's make sure that it's really
good meaning from a quality perspective
you don't get dizzy you don't get a
headache and so on so these guys have
spent a considerable amount of time and
we've been tracking this very closely
figuring out what does it take to build
a good VR experience on a phone or using
a phone as your screen with a headset of
course and this takes a huge amount of
engineering work also from us which is
why being part of this daydream program
we're gonna be making what's called a
dream ready phones it's a big deal
because really the bar is very high yeah
mostly because if the difference between
for example your head moving and the
screen updating is more than 20
milliseconds your brain notices right so
to make phones that can update the
screen as quickly requires a lot of
engineering but so what's the time frame
on this is this like near-term and this
sounds futurist so Google was saying
these phones will start coming out much
later this year so I think this is like
this is mostly a 2017 thing from the
point of view of the chipsets that it
requires the kinds of screens that you
requires and so on and so forth so yours
will be on time we haven't actually
finalized yeah exactly which product in
the wind but it's later this year
sometime early next year that's what
we're thinking roughly now on the issue
of smart phones Xiaomi missed its
targets for last year you said that you
thought you might sell 80 to 100 million
phones you sold 70 million what do you
think happened so first we don't really
have set targets I think that was a
number that became a target somehow the
way to think about it is well first of
all very very competitive industry
secondly we really are focused on user
acquisition right so we're focused on
acquiring Internet users more
importantly than selling phones it also
supply chain as well you know we
obviously make phones as quickly as we
possibly can demand is much higher than
than what we've supplied so far so we're
still ramping up right we're still
ramping up constantly ramping up but the
key point here is we
don't measure ourselves on how many
phones we sell we measure ourselves on
how many Internet users we acquire how
many hours a day do they span consuming
these services which we monetize and of
course how much revenue per user are we
generating now we don't talk about these
things openly but these are the numbers
that we look at the most close to the
internally so the global smartphone
market is saturating and it's saturating
in China how do you overcome that so it
is what trans are you it is certainly a
saturating market you know we estimate
China will top up will top out at about
half a billion phones a year which is a
big number by the way so there's some
growth opportunity for us in China
particularly as online by the way which
is the channel that we almost own
continues to grow as a percentage to a
retail price so there's a huge room for
us to grow in China still but we're
we're obviously going for growth as well
in expansion our other markets India is
the market that we've chosen as our
second market in the world that's where
I spent as you know a lot of my time and
we continue to hit sales records in
India so our business and India is going
super any update time when you'll be
selling phones here in the US so we're
obviously getting closer or we're you
know starting to do preparation work to
launch in the US but it's further sort
of out what I could even easily predict
now here we're not talking about
launching phones in the US this year to
be clear yeah you know but it's
something that we're we're working on
it's gonna take a while obviously
preparing phones for the wireless
spectrum in the u.s. setting up after
sales having all of our operations up
and running knowing how to do marketing
here and so on one of the reasons by the
way while we're launching this product
right it's the product made for the US
market we're gonna learn how to do
business here Xiaomi drones when are
they coming
there was a hint yesterday we talked
about it yesterday online showing a
picture of a potential Xiaomi drone is
that happening we are excited about
consumer electronics in general you know
we've made as you know huge investments
into a number of companies from the from
our self balancing scooter you know nine
bought with Segway technology all the
way to home appliances we're very
interested in in cool electronics which
are connected
you know especially things to do with
photography and video and so on and so
forth so it wouldn't be a terrible guess
but I can't say anymore at this place